you did it Jamie I know I mean you
seemed pretty shocked when they said
your name totally shocked are you
kidding I mean I was so well deserved
though that's very sweet of you to say
you know I just can't go there I just am
so the nicest thing and I'm what I'm now
of course you know because I was so
surprised I did not write something down
as you could tell
well that's the only way I would never
be able to write something down like
that
um
I wanted to acknowledge that the women
with me have become my friends and that
I I didn't know that was going to happen
I knew Stephanie of course but I didn't
know the rest of these women and we met
over Zoom we met in these panels and we
met talking about each of our lives and
our work and I've become I've become
friends with them like Hong has a little
baby she had a baby right before making
that movie Angela came with her daughter
she's this beautiful grown teenage
daughter who I thought oh can you
imagine having Angela Bassett as my
mother as this force of beauty and
strength in nature and Carrie Condon we
run at each other like kind of school
girls we're like oh and
we've become friends and that is the
nicest thing to take away and I'm
telling you this is lovely and heavy but
the truth of the matter is for me in the
season of shiny things in all of this
tremendous amounts of attention
the nicest thing is that now I feel like
I have five girlfriends and there is a
Sisterhood for sure and on top of it of
course my cast who I love and
um who we've been to for three years
together on this project he just won
right after just one I know and he'll be
here I know you know obviously you
couldn't have predicted this which means
you totally didn't predict this you
probably didn't plan to kiss Michelle yo
too when you were going to accept your
trophy right I kissed her you did
another meme is born right did I really
I kissed her
there was a moment then I kissed her
you know what honestly
I really I'm I mean I know where I am I
know but I'm but I love Michelle yo we
were we love each other we've we fell in
love with each other she's married I met
her husband in England he's lovely I
also have a husband of course you know
you had made a joke at the beginning of
the show about being a nepo baby but
then on the stage you got to
I joke about it because it's the thing
that people like to joke about but the
truth of the matter is
um I've been doing this for a very long
time and I'm I've never worked for
anybody I ever knew
I mean no one I've only worked with
strangers and so the truth of the matter
is obviously it was a it was a help
obviously I know a lot about show off
business obviously
you know I mean look I'm not going to
pretend that there was no effect of
having them as my parents but
I'm 64 years old I've been an actress
since I was 19. and I only bring that up
to say that you've yourself had a force
as a mother you know and you got to pay
tribute to her tonight with this ring if
we may see it and also I mean I I
brought it up because as I was dressing
and putting on my beautiful jewelry from
Kathy Waterman to accompany my outfit
there was this ring and I don't wear it
I don't wear pinky rings you know and it
was the ring that my father married my
mother with and I just put it on because
I thought I'd bring them with me and not
be for good luck just to have them be in
the room
thank you
[Music]